back in 2010 developer frictional games
set the tone for pc
in the horror with amnesia the dark
descent with amnesia rebirth
it feels like frictional has finally
refined its story-driven atmospheric
approach to horror
you're trapped in a deadly smothering
world struggling against your
character's limitations and even her
perceptions
rebirth is frictional's best game yet
marrying a deep mysterious story
to the signature mechanics the developer
has been working with over the course of
13 years of horror games
amnesia rebirth continues frictional
specific approach to story and horror
which emphasizes avoiding conflict
hiding and mastering your character's
own fear
it adds to the story of the dark descent
although you don't need to know that
game well to follow this narrative
and it doesn't connect to amnesia a
machine for pigs at all
you play as tassie trionen a french
woman who joins a mining expedition to
algeria in 1937.
in the opening moments of the game the
expedition's plane experiences some
supernatural shenanigans that cause it
to crash in the desert
tosi wakes up soon after alone in the
plane with few memories of what happened
and strange black tendrils creeping into
her vision
as she goes searching for survivors she
discovers that the strange bracelet
she's wearing can open portals to a dark
ruined parallel world tassie goes
searching through caves and tunnels for
her friends
and the story often pulls her into the
alternate dimension as she tries to find
her way forward
rebirth brings back the main mechanics
from the dark descent and really
all of frictional's games deal in
similar sets of ideas
you trace the survivor's path gathering
notes and uncovering clues as to what
happened
you're quickly plunged into darkness
which increases tassie's fear and
affects her psyche
itasi gets too scared the blackness
overtakes her causing her to wake up
somewhere else with no memory of how she
got there
the more frightened tassie becomes the
less reliable her perceptions
you start to see frightening flashes
across the screen as she becomes more
terrified
and rebirth plays off your inability to
see much around you with sound design
that emphasizes the echoing
oppressive nature of the places you work
through just as things are starting to
get spooky or dangerous
images start to flash in your vision to
create jump scares and the addition of
sound and movement in your periphery
makes it tougher to trust your senses
you're often hearing things that might
be lurking just outside of your vision
and rebirth increases your terror by
making it difficult to tell if those
things are hallucinations
ambient noise or actual dangers waiting
in the dark
to fight the fear you're always on the
hunt for light
finding books of matches all over the
environment you can use to push back the
darkness
matches quickly burn out but you can use
them to ignite torches
candles sconces and other light sources
as you explore
you'll spend a lot of your time lighting
every flammable thing you can find
but this has the drawback of leaving you
with fewer places to hide from whatever
is making those upsetting chewing sounds
somewhere beyond your vision
like frictional's other games you can
interact with most everything you see in
rebirth
using your mouse or controller to
simulate motions like pushing open doors
or moving objects
you use those physical interactions to
solve puzzles that block your progress
while none of the puzzles are especially
difficult it's definitely possible to
get stalled out as you search for a
solution that's not immediately
intuitive
for the most part though the obstacles
rebirth throws in your path are
inventive without being annoyed
while you're exploring you'll also have
to contend with actual terrors hiding in
the shadows
you can't fight the monsters skittering
in the dark you can only hide or flee
from them
that leads to a variety of frightening
chases and stealthy moments as you sneak
past something horrifying while it hunts
you
balancing using shadows to hide yourself
and keeping taci's fears from
overwhelming her
it's in these brushes with supernatural
horrors that rebirth represents the
biggest step forward for frictional
games
your only measure for how tassy is
faring is her increasing heart rate
and the black encroaching across her
vision as her fear rises
but if a creature catches you it doesn't
kill you forcing you to reload a
checkpoint and pretend nothing happened
instead if things get bad enough the
black tendrils overtake tassie
and you find yourself somewhere else it
might sound like the lack of deadly
enemies means it lacks stakes but the
game still does a great job
of creating frightening moments but
removes the frustration of having to
replay a section after dying
and it feels like a natural evolution
from frictionals past games
this is a game about a spooky story and
while horror games work to create
moments of fear and tension
a lot of what makes them scary gets
ruined by playing the same section of
the game over and over
storytelling is rebirth's real focus
although the intricate tale it tells is
undercut somewhat by the limitations of
small games and the trappings of first
person horror
most of the game is about tassie finding
her way alone reading notes and
remembering tidbits of stories that
happened off-screen
those flashbacks are largely presented
as dialogue over drawings
and that can make it tough to understand
or connect with the many characters
mentioned along the way
tasi's personal story which focuses on
her experiences as a mother
is a lot stronger her relationships with
her daughter and her husband
and the traumas of her past inform a lot
of her actions as rebirth progresses
although it's not until late in the game
that you really start to understand
tossy as a character
thanks to her amnesia rebirth is
unabashedly a mom game
and it's at its best when tassie's
personal journey intersects with the
supernatural
precious tune and look at you
though sneaking past or fleeing from
monsters is often harrowing there are
moments when encounters won't quite
terrify
the creatures sometimes seem a bit dumb
as you slip past them and one or two
chases move fairly slowly
making it apparent you're really not in
as much danger as the game would like
you to believe
the limitation that you can't actually
look at enemies because it drives up
tossy's fear
can also seem a bit arbitrary at times
with a few moments that wouldn't be very
scary or challenging
if you could actually see what you're
avoiding still amnesia rebirth feels
like the culmination of frictional games
horror titles up to this point
it refines the ideas and mechanics that
have been central to the developers
games all along
it hones in on effective scares while
avoiding the frustrations of failure
and it tightens the focus on
character-driven storytelling
amnesia rebirth is an unsettling strange
tragic story
that deepens the amnesia mythos in a lot
of cool ways
while managing to be just as creepy and
frightening as its beloved predecessor
[Music]
you